meantime other news here at five a woman
is urging a lot of caution after her
u-haul was stolen during a stop in las
vegas
but it contained irreplaceable items
from her daughter
who recently passed away as kate houston
reports the mother says this was almost
like
losing her daughter for a second time
it's a lot of memories
i know it's only things but it means a
lot sheila deibel biss was in the
process of moving from los angeles to
wyoming
following her daughter's passing from
ovarian cancer
we should always be with me no matter
what in my heart in my spirit
las vegas was one of many stops to
spread her daughter's ashes
this way she can travel the winds
and say hello to all her friends
and it brought closure to a lot of
people but what started as a memorial
road trip
soon felt like another loss on sunday
divalbus woke to find her u-haul missing
i asked my friend am i imagining this
and she looked out and we couldn't get
dressed fast enough
inside irreplaceable mementos and
memories of her daughter
and parents heirlooms i've been given
everything my daughter had was in there
she was an illustrator her
artwork monday morning the u-haul was
found damaged with the tools to break in
left on the front seat a tv over a
thousand dollars worth of items
suitcases personal files and artwork
were all stolen
my daughter's artwork meant everything
to me i mean they're framed
she had them professionally framed
they're one of a kind pieces she used to
sell at art shows
now divelbis is warning other drivers to
stay alert
even in areas they deemed safe try to
park under a light
you know if you can back it up against a
fence where they can't open the back of
your yule
take a photo of the side the back and
the license plate
kate houston 8 news now
so while there was damage to the u-haul
diver bliss says the company was quick
to repair it she hopes to get back on
the road as early as tonight